اذهبوا الى مراسلين من دونيتس كمراسله
الجزيره كارمن جو خضار ومن كييف مراسلنا
حسان مسعود
ومن واشنطن مراسلنا احمد هزيمه ابدا معك
كيف يبدو الوضع الجبهات مع هذه المعطيات
التي يبدو بانه بدء للهجوم المضاده
الاوكراني
نعم سلمى في انعكاسات هذه الهجمات المكثفه
على عدد من الجبهات في مدينه دنيات يتكثف
القصف الاوكراني على وسط هذه المدينه قبل
قليل اسقطت الدفاعات الجويه في وسط
دانياسك صاروخا من نوع هايمرز داخل هذه
المدينه
واظهرت الصور الوارده من حيل ننسكي
بالتحديد اجزاء من هذا الصاروخ ولم يصب اي
شخص باي ضرر هذا القصف يتكثف اذ ان وسط
مدينه يقع بين شمالا جبهه افدي جنوب جبهه
مارينكا واوبلدار وبالتالي هذه المدينه
يمكن القول انها تقصف بشكل متكرر وحتى في
بعض الاحياء صدرت تحذيرات قبل قليل من
السلطات المحليه للاهالي لعدم الخروج من
منازلهم الا للضروره اليوم الجبهات كلها
يمكن القول تتحرك وتتفاعل من شمال
هناك تم الحديث عن معارك في احد الاجنحه
مالك شركه فاجنر تحدث عن هذا الامر ولاحقه
ايضا تصريح من دينيس بوشيلين القائم
باعمال مقاطعه الموالي لروسيا تحدث ايضا
بوشلن عن صعوبه المعارك في جبهه مارينكا
وقال ان القوات الروسيه تقوم
وهي تؤازرها قوات احمد الشيشانيه تتقدم في
هذه الجبهه الجنوبيه من مقاطعه
اخرى تتحرك وتتفاعل بشكل كبير وكل الانظار
شخص اليها سلمى في دنيا
هناك تحركات وهجمات اوكرانيه متتاليه على
تلك الجبهه ولكن جبهات دانياتك على
اهميتها ومساعي القوات الروسيه لاستكمال
سيطراتها على هذه المقاطعه بالمقابل السعي
الاوكراني لاختراق تحصينات القوات الروسيه
يقابله ايضا تحركات في عدد من قطعات اكان
خرسون او ذابولوجيا كانت مسرحه لتحركات
اوكرانيه واستهدافات اوكرانيا تحدثت عنها
السلطات ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه وبدورها
ايضا قالت انها استهدفت هذه القوات واحبطت
هجوماتها ومساعها للتقدم اليوم تؤكد
القوات الروسيه انها تسعى للتقدم وفي
الوقت ذاته تحبط كل هذه الهجمات حسام
مسعود في كييف كيف بدت التصريحات الرسميه
الاوكرانيه ماشيه مع ما يجري على الارض
[موسيقى]
التصريحات الاوكرانيه تنوعت ما بين محاوله
الاحتفاظ بالصمت في التعليق على هذه
الاحداث الجاريه تحديدا في المنطقه
الشرقيه ثم تطورت لتقديم بعض الاشارات
والمعلومات عن تطورات وتحركات عسكريه في
المنطقه الشرقيه ثم وصلت الى حديث نائبه
وزيره او وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ان مليار بشكل واضح عن قيام
القوات
الاوكرانيه بتنفيذ هجمات في منطقه
خورتيتسيا وهذه المنطقه هي المنطقه
الواقعه شرقيه اوكرانيا وكذلك جنوب شرقي
منطقه
دونياتك وتحديدا بالقرب من مقاطعه هذه
المنطقه تشهد بشكل واضح ووفق اعلان رسمي
الان على عدد من الهجمات الاوكرانيه في
عدد من الاتجاهات وهو ايضا ما تشير اليه
عدد من التحركات العسكريه وكذلك الرصد
التي تقوم به مواقع متخصصه برصد التحركات
القوات العسكريه عند الجبهات الاوكرانيه
وايضا يضاف الى ذلك حديث من جانب قائد
القوات البريه عن ايضا تحركات باتجاه
مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه في منطقه
باخمت هذا كله يشير الى ان عدد من الجبهات
الاوكرانيه تحديدا في المنطقه الشرقيه
باتت اكثر اشتعالا في هذه الفتره وان
الفتره الماضيه التي كانت توجه فيها
الانظار نحو المنطقه الجنوبيه ربما تكون
هي محاوله جديده من جانب القوات
الاوكرانيه لتضليل الجانب الروسي وتقديم
معلومات مغلوطه حول النيه الهجوم المضاد
والوجهه التي تريد اوكرانيا ان تنفذ فيها
الهجوم المضاده سيما بدايه هذا الهجوم قبل
العوده الى مناطق اخرى ولكن بكل الاحوال
هذه التحركات كنا قد
ولاحظناها خلال المرات السابقه التي شهدت
فيها اوكرانيا هجمات مضاده سواء كانت في
خاركيف او في خرسون كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول ان توجه الانظار نحو جهه
معينه نحو وجهه معينه لكن بعد بدء هذا
الهجوم يتبين ان الوجهه هي وجهه اخرى كان
هناك ايضا تصريح لافت من جانب المتحدث
باسم قوات الجنوب ان تاليوك التي اشارت
بشكل واضح الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه تعمل
على تضليل الجانب الروسي
وتبقي القوات الروسيه في حاله تاهب
وجهوزيه على امتداد الجبهه الممتده على
طول 450 كيلو مترا وهي محاوله مقصوده من
الجانب الاوكراني كما قالت
لتشتيت جهود القوات الروسيه
لتتمكن القوات الاوكرانيه من تنفيذي خطتها
بشكل واضح وفق ما تخطط وتس